(Madelyn)
Listen, I’m going to be late.
They’ve put me on another flight.
(Ali)
I love you baby.
[boom]
(Howard)
There’s been an incident,
A 950 has disappeared over the Atlantic.
[explosion]
[screaming]
(Kendra)
I’m sorry Howard...
(Howard)
I need you.
You’re the only one who can find this plane.
[boom]
[screaming]
(Dom)
It is strange there was no Mayday of any kind.
(Levi)
It could have been a highjacking.
[boom]
[explosion]
(Kendra)
Somebody onbaord wanted that aircraft to disappear.
(Dom)
They found debris.
(Kendra)
No.
A survivor.
[helicoptor]
(Kendra)
Is our miracle survivor our prime suspect?
(Ali)
Is this an interrogation?
What are you accusing me of?
(Kendra)
It wasn’t an accident.
(Dom)
Terrorist causes crash.
(Kendra)
Could look like an act of war.
(Dom)
A van’s following us.
(Kendra)
People went to great lengths to cover up
what crashed flight 716.
(Kendra)
I go where the evidence takes me.
(Howard)
It’s not possible.
(Kendra)
We need to hear what happened on that flight,
we need to know the truth.